[Music]
hey what's up I hate my new boss you
made all of your bosses this guy is the
[ __ ] worst I have to wear this stupid
job oh come on Seth called a jabo it's
stupid
and it's freaking night shift is killing
live you start at the bottom with the
night shifts and you work your way up
the day show I don't think there is a
day shift
this guy is a weirdo okay his kid is all
pale and chalky he looks like a crispy
powdered donut - I know I don't think he
gets out much
he's like 4,000 years old stop
complaining cuz I would do anything for
a job right now not this guy I mean I
can handle a micromanager but it's like
every time I get up he's just been
standing there the whole time breathing
down my neck like oh oh and there's this
awful mothball smell I don't know if
it's just when he's in that form he's
standing right behind me isn't he
don't worry we've got the good health
insurance whatever as long as I can log
these hours you know some people would
kill to look from oh are you ain't
positive you go great with Malibu oh and
thanks for the Coppertone SPF a billion
anything to keep my boss alive yeah I am
Alive